in our series of more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us today we introduce you to an
inspiring woman behind a small coffee
shop about an hour south of Chicago Meg
Oliver shows us how this java joint is
percolating with great coffee and acts
of kindness on this corner in Crown
Point Indiana sits a cafe at the heart
of the community every day at Cafe
fresco a small staff bustles behind the
counter brewing coffee and inspiration
with handwritten encouragement on its
cup sleeves I think this one believe
there is good in the world be the good
some might say 31 year-old Brianne zopo
is better than good the former nanny
opened this coffeehouse six years ago
and on a whim started writing the
uplifting messages for customers I just
hope that it would like add some
positive life to their day customer
reaction was overwhelming so much that
she took it further just have to go drop
change in the Salvation Army jar and
film it challenging them to perform good
deeds for a free cup of joe pay for
someone's coffee donate clothes to a
homeless shelter so how many free cups
of coffee have you given out oh that's
such a good business plan I mean I feel
like if you're spreading positivity like
people want to be a part of positivity
like good people helping good people the
fabric of Crown Point is tightly net and
for Zoll folks serving that community
goes well beyond the walls of her cafe
instead of pocketing the cash from the
stores tip jar she pays it forward every
month
on this day she uses the money to
surprise shoppers at a nearby
supermarket positivity people come to
thank you yeah what's that like we had
this one person that he was homeless and
we had bought a bike for him and he came
back two years later after we had
purchased the bike for him and he said
you don't know how much you've changed
my life like because you bought me a
bike I got a job and I got an apartment
and they even talking about it makes me
car hate and how has this changed the
community I hope that it's spread
positivity throughout like not just this
community but other communities that are
around us for us to play a small part in
a lot of people's lives is the most
amazing feeling it's a Java inspired
boost the entire community of Crown
Point can rally behind
for CBS this morning
meg Oliver Crown Point Indiana well
brian has the right idea about spreading
kindness you can be done very easily see
what what what the simple kindness of
donating a bike can do change the one's
life right yeah I want to go visit but
it was a great story